so Elon Musk has gone and done it Elon
Musk has appointed a new CEO to Twitter
a woman who is an executive chair for
the world economic forum and already you
can see the backlash I started thinking
about this right away because uh we
signed up recently to be a verified
organization it costs over a thousand
dollars a month for these corporate
benefits that you get with Twitter and I
I like them I think they're good you get
prioritized reach uh placement you get
to verify all of your employees you get
a gold badge you get an affiliation
badge along with verification if you
work for the company
but who would I be if I told all of you
to stop drinking Bud Light and then I
kept paying a company that put an
executive chair of the world economic
Forum on its uh c-suite as the chief
executive officer I think I'd be a
hypocrite so in the uh poll on this live
show I have asked you should we timcast
remove our Twitter blue over the
appointment of a world economic Forum
chief executive officer so far the poll
as of the launch of this uh of this show
is it about 66 so we're going to talk a
lot about that before we get started my
friends head over to castbrew.com if you
want to support the show this is our
company our coffee company we are
sponsoring ourselves you can join the
cast Brew Coffee Club you get three bags
of coffee every single month and it's a
discounted rate you save about five or
six bucks but we also have several other
Blends like rise with Roberto Jr
Appalachian nights unfortunately rise
with Roberto Jr is sold out but we'll be
back very very soon so if you want to go
to casper.com and support the show
please do so also head over to
timcast.com click join us and become a
member if you would like to support us
directly you'll get access to our
Discord server where you can hang out
with like-minded individuals and why
watch the uncensored members only show
Monday through Thursday so smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share this show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and a lot more is tutor Dixon thank you
I'm excited to be here thanks for coming
who are you what do you do well I ran
for governor in the state of Michigan I
have a podcast now the Tudor Dixon
podcast and we are working on what we
can do to win elections so that's the
plan going forward right on uh I guess
before we even get started you've got
plans to run again
maybe someday all right I say maybe it's
like pregnancy and then you forget and
do it again there you go so okay well
thanks for hanging out this should be a
lot of fun uh we already had a lot we
were talking a lot before the show
started and it was really good so I'm
excited we got Phil abati hanging out
how you doing I am philibonti lead
singer of All That Remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
here with my good friend hi I'm Taylor
Silverman I'm a skateboarder and I work
on the show cast Castle here at Tim Cass
and for domistan and newly coming soon
free download I didn't want to say
anything because I didn't want to make
any announcements again yeah but um I
just recently did tutors podcasts also
so it's really cool to meet you in
person yeah it is it she was great
awesome and we were very excited to have
you because she's a michigander too oh
yeah yeah so there's like a connection
we're not too far either no like hour
and a half yeah right on what's up
everybody uh it's Kellen uh Fridays are
the best days as I always say I'm ready
to get started when you guys are all
right let's jump into this first store
we got this on Twitter itself from Elon
Musk he says I'm am excited to welcome
Linda yaccarino as the new CEO of
Twitter Linda Yak will focus primarily
on business operations while I focus on
product design and new technology
looking forward to working with Linda to
transform this platform into X that
every the everything app okay well
here you go
here's a well I guess uh maybe I can
shrink this so you can see it better
apparently not well you can see right
here World economic Forum this is from
her LinkedIn
executive chair January 2019 to present
I took a screenshot of this because I
don't want to show the rest of her
private details but I think this is
particularly relevant and publicly
available yeah Carino is the chairman of
the world economic forum's task force on
a future of work and sits on the web's
media entertainment and culture industry
Governors steering committee she is also
highly engaged with the value in media
initiative
immediately I don't trust her I uh don't
I look I like Elon Musk I think he's
doing a lot of really important things I
think SpaceX is one of the most
important things humanity is doing
period And I think him buying Twitter
was already very very good but I think
this is a huge mistake if only because
he has shattered confidence in the
platform to the point where I have
pulled up right now the verified orgs
subscription uh plan and before I
clicked deactivate our account which
would suspend payments to Twitter for
the corporate benefits for Twitter
balloon verification I decided to put a
poll up and it's already sitting at 70
saying yes we should terminate our
subscription to Twitter over this so I'm
curious what you guys think
I mean I think that we have to be honest
with who Elon Musk is you know we I we
were talking about how we like to glob
on to someone who we believe is a
conservative because they agree with one
of our values and he's very he's been
very adamant that he wants Free Speech
but he's also a globalist we know this I
mean he's he's made that very clear so
we can't expect that Twitter is going to
be this place that's not going to be
leaning that way or that he's not going
to be leaning that way so I think you
have to do what you think is right for
your company and for your company this
is not where you are for obvious reasons
I'm not concerned about whether or not
elon's conservative right I I you know I
I argue with Sheamus over abortion but I
think in in the modern culture war in in
our current culture War the traditional
pro-choice position is substantially
closer to pro-life than the left's
current position on abortion to the
point of birth which is terrifying to me
so it seems like they're they're
creating this uh the culture War has
created this perception that liberals
and conservatives are almost the same
thing because of how radically different
they are but if Elon Musk comes out and
says I'm going to give the Libertarians
disaffected liberals conservatives the
right to speak on this platform we think
it's a good thing
the issue for me is appointing this
woman says to me party's over
honeymoon's over the censorship will
slowly start creeping back in and we are
going right back to the beginning
I think that I mean liberalism has a
weakness in that it does take other
philosophies at their face value as if
they are honest and right now the like
the woke mind virus whatever you want to
call it the the the current popular
brand of leftism is subversive it's
intentionally subversive so if a liberal
takes them at their at face value you
often end up with modern Bailey
arguments you often end up with all
kinds of uh emotional arguments uh
because the left doesn't fundamentally
believe the same things that liberals do
Elon Musk is a liberal he believes that
open dialogue is always good and I think
that it is but you have to understand
that just because you're liberal
everyone around you does not is not
liberal like people believe that they're
liberal nowadays there are people that
will say they're liberal and then they
will go ahead and advocate for
authoritarian type policies like you
know clamping down on Free Speech you
can't say this you can't say that you
can't have this opinion that's a bad
thing
um and I don't know if Elon is as aware
as he needs to be of how dangerous and
how intentionally subversive the left is
nowadays you can't take people like that
at their word because they are they play
with meanings they play with definitions
um and and I think that if he's aware
it's possible that he could navigate
that uh but it's not easy because people
like that will tend to find other people
like that that share their opinions and
they'll invite them in and hire them and
that's what happened in in colleges in
in education that's why you have such a
monolithic ideology coming out of
colleges now so I want to pull up this
article from vox.com who is Linda
yakarino Elon musk's pick for the new
Twitter CEO and they mentioned that here
let me just read this is it although
yakarino is not vocal about our
political beliefs it is well known in
the advertising community that she's
conservative according to several
sources she served on former president
Donald Trump's Council on Sports and
nutrition and many have noted that she
likes and follows conservative accounts
on Twitter but she's also drawn flag
from the right some of the more extreme
right-wing Twitter influencer accounts
have criticized her for praising
diversity in the workforce and for being
chair of the task force on the future of
work at the world economic Forum which
they view as an elitist organization I
mean that's putting it lightly they view
as can I mean if you can't go to the
meetings and and just show up it is well
I mean it's a globalist yeah secretive
elitist but uh if she's a conservative
does that I mean is it a good thing is
it about is is her participation in the
world economic Forum disqualifying
because we don't trust the world
economic form the Davos group and their
policies what if she's actually a
conservative which means we're going to
get more right-leaning or Center
center-ish policies
I think it calls for serious scrutiny
serious serious scrutiny uh I'm not
ready to just swear off and say you know
screw off it's it's time to go jump into
the old bunker and and you know expect
the the bombs to start falling in the
end of the world but it is completely
reasonable to look at this person and
say look your history and things that
you've said in videos I've seen clips
and stuff that have been put up on
Twitter already things that she said
it's she is very very suspect so well
scrutiny I guess the idea is
she is well known in the advertising
community and so
elon's view most likely is that she's
going to restore faith and bring the for
the advertisers and bring them back to
the platform but there's only one way
you do that and that's caving to woke
nonsense how how involved do you think
he is at this point I mean it you can
get rid of a CEO she's going to be
tested we're all going to we're all
going to make it known if we don't like
her I mean I think it's going to be
interesting because
to be CEO you shouldn't really we
shouldn't be judging are you
conservative are you liberal are you a
good manager of something like this and
this is a business if she's managing it
well then it shouldn't be that she's
going after people for their Ideology
Now I don't know if she is in the
situation of being a chair of the world
economic Forum if she's able to pull
herself away from that and look at this
from a business venture standpoint
because if you're a good business person
the majority of businesses across the
world do not look at things politically
we think they do because we see the Bud
Lights of the world but most companies
are like stay out of the political let's
make a profit let's make it work let's
uh let me pull up this tweet from
billboard Chris who responded to Elon
Muskie said during the inter during her
interview with you she was most excited
about your initiative to limit reach of
tweets which are deemed hateful freedom
of speech not freedom of reach in fact
that was her main selling point to the
advertising execs in the audience and
she kept coming back to it she went on
to chastise you twice for tweeting after
3 A.M because people are concerned about
that sort of behavior what she also
wanted advertising execs to be part of
an influence Council within Twitter
she's not here to improve the user
experience she wants Twitter to be a
safe space she represents advertisers
and her natural inclination is to limit
speech and Panda to those who push woke
ideology on the world you will have to
watch her like a hawk she was also
thrilled to spend 100 million dollars on
social justice initiatives at NBC and
forwarded government authoritarian
propaganda that the way back to a normal
life was to wear your mask no doubt
she'll bring in advertising Revenue in
the short term but she's a long-term
mistake Elon responded and said I hear
your concerns but don't judge too early
I am adamant about defending Free Speech
even if it means losing money well I'm
going to put it this way
I believe
in the preliminary view with her resume
is that I should not be giving Twitter
any money
and if she then proves she's going right
doing right by the company then I'll
give the company money so I've already
given Twitter some money
signing up for the verified
organizations in Twitter blue for the
company It's relatively expensive
bringing this woman on
I I feel is a very big risk
I don't want to fuel any more of this
ESG Welk garbage
if this woman works the world economic
Forum which is a major proponent of this
stuff I am going to limit my giving them
money maybe in a couple months I will
revisit the prospect of signing back up
if she's doing a good job but this is
I feel like it's
whether it's a betrayal of trust or not
is irrelevant I feel like it's just
advertisers leave Elon says we got to
make money I say don't worry I'll give
you money Elon I believe in what you're
doing he then says okay welcome the
world economic Forum chair on the future
of work and I say oh okay well now I now
I don't know what you're doing and I
don't know if I believe in it I don't
want to give these people money well
okay so let's go a little deeper on the
advertisers leaving thing because why
are advertisers leaving anything that is
considered conservative and why are we
allowing these threats and I think
activists but but they're getting them
de-platform debanked all of these things
and so why are we I see politicians
going after individual businesses and I
say why aren't we going after these
people that are debanking the banks that
are debanking why aren't we making this
illegal instead of going after Case by
case and trying to hit the business go
after the source of the problem and stop
that from happening so we don't end up
having people go I'm going to hire
somebody that I think can get Market or
that I think can get advertisers because
advertisers are so finicky why are they
finicky because we are allowing this
bullying system that is really stopping
people from being able to bank I mean
made if you debank someone they're toast
yeah so where are all of the the
politicians that are going well we can
allow this to continue happening I think
uh
the debanking stuff is a sign that
there's going to be some kind of serious
financial crash and they're trying to do
everything to push everyone towards
towards the digital currencies and they
want a central bank digital currency and
I was actually listening to some guy
talk about there's this apple just
announced this bank account with four
percent interest and I'm hearing
everybody be like I have to set one of
those things up four percent interest
that's that's that's huge I mean
inflation's way worse than that if
you're tracking the real numbers but
four percent is big for a savings
account and so now I'm hearing that this
is causing an upset in the financial
industry to a certain degree at least
I'm not a financial guy I don't know for
sure but that why get a CD at three
point eight or four percent if a savings
account with apple is better and you
don't gotta wait for it to to mature or
whatever and so we're just we're seeing
stuff like that and I don't know what
that really means all I know is I see
people saying they're concerned about it
we're seeing Banks collapse we're seeing
debanking and I'm wondering if the big
move is going to be get everybody onto
digital currency currencies big collapse
happens Central Bank digital currency
gets launched I can't say whether or not
that's the actual plan but I know that
nowadays there are a lot more options
for people when it comes to banking
Financial technologies have really taken
off things like Bitcoin showed that
digital types of currencies uh can
actually work and so obviously you see
banks that exist coming up in companies
now obviously with apple doing it with
offering bank accounts or whatever
um you're gonna see more Innovations in
the financial technology sector unless
the government completely shuts it down
so I don't know that they're going to
but I would expect without a
Central Bank digital currency I would
expect more options and more
possibilities for people to come from
the private sector because that's what
that's what happens but what does that
mean as you stretch money across those
different areas if you have so many
different options then how does anything
stay safe stable because if you take
money out of banks then banks are not
Stables so you have to look at this and
say well somebody has to kind of say
well there has to be some control so
that everything's not crashing you're
talking to a Libertarian here kind of
dude so I'm like no just straight up no
like I think that there are all there
are there are tons of options for ways
to save your value things that you have
you know whether it be money or whether
it be Bitcoin different cryptocurrencies
there's a ton of different you know
currencies in the world that people can
say I think these are better than
dollars for whatever crazy reason they
come up with you can buy gold you can
buy silver there's already so many
different ways to store currency and
save currency and save value uh just a
few more Banks or more options that are
now new technology I don't think that's
any kind of significant problem I don't
think it's a problem at all I think that
that that's something that we can handle
I mean people most people that have a
significant amount of wealth it's
usually in stocks we're frequently in
stocks and stuff like that in owning
companies so I don't know that I don't
know that it needs to be controlled by
the the Federal Reserve I think that
that the markets will control that kind
of stuff so that's just my take back to
Twitter for a second do you think we're
going to see a lot of people stop paying
for Twitter to at least give it some
time to see how it plays out
or do they want that blue check really
bad no I think that it's I mean I don't
know it'll be interesting because for
some people I think it's their business
and they feel like that's a service they
subscribe to and so maybe they'll watch
and see and then I think that once they
see the first the first signs of what
you're concerned about that's when
you'll see people just immediately drop
it I was gonna say I think maybe that's
the appropriate response instead of just
canceling everything out right
basically just saying to Elon my view is
this is thin ice and if we see one bad
move like we're skittish we are we are
running but for the time being I really
want I really want to believe I really
want Elon to succeed in this endeavor
and if the issue is he's looking at the
bottom line like we need advertisers and
this woman worked in the Trump
Administration I'm like okay you know
she was in the Trump Administration yeah
okay well I mean I mean Trump picked
well that's what people are saying right
I'm pretty right exactly that's why I'm
like I don't know I think that you have
to think of it from she's a known Trump
supporter according to Vox
so she she would you would think that
doing this you would be very careful not
to immediately make changes and and make
a lot of people mad because you saw what
just happened with Bud Light I mean they
literally are giving a 15 rebate right
now with every case you buy you know
really yeah
it's a disaster for them but but if
that's the reaction why would they take
the chance of everybody dropping their
subscription which which I mean
obviously this happened with big
corporations just recently so it's quite
possible but like you said I think that
you wait and you see if this is what
happens then conservatives are not going
to hesitate they've made that clear now
we're just done with this woke stuff if
you're gonna do it we're out my favorite
thing about Twitter since Elon took over
is that he has brought back freedom of
speech to an extent which I think a lot
of people value and that's not
necessarily a conservative value it's
pretty crazy that people think that is
now and um the Lord Chris's remarks like
talking about uh what she said freedom
of speech not freedom of reach I wonder
what is deemed hateful like who's
defining that the the big the big play
for the left is to argue that free
speech is conservative so that they can
make anything they don't like right wing
and then anything so so right means bad
left means good yep so from now on I'm
just gonna call them right wing it's
like it's it's and I'm and I'm gonna say
it's always been the right that was
anti-free Speech free speech is like the
ultimate Rebel move yeah so they're all
they're all right far right well if
you're not on the left you're far right
experience even if you're on the left
and you say one thing out of line you're
a far right extremist now it doesn't
take very much to step out of line on
the left
oh yeah just gotta call him far right
although left and right are relatively
meaningless these days just means like
which tribe are you in but that's what
they try to do and then how do you how
do you fight back against that when you
say I'm for free speech that well then
you're conservative the argument they're
making is free speech is a traditional
position and banning hate speeches the
progressive position right so you are
you are old and archaic if you support
the old way of doing things but but it's
also helpful to not teach history so we
just saw that the Proficiency in history
is at the lowest levels in the United
States ever so if you don't know what
happens when you ban speech if you don't
know that people were you know killed or
kept in prison because they went against
the king then you don't know why the
founding fathers were so admit that we
had to be able to say whatever we want
even if they don't like it even if it's
burning the American flag if even if
it's something that seems so awful they
want you to be able to say it because
once you start to it's a slippery slope
once you start to take it away then
everybody it'll hurt them too that's the
funny thing it will hurt them too I feel
like conservatives have become liberal
in the literal sense of things like
Liberals are far left extremists not
really most of them are just ignorant
but then there's a lot of people who are
quote unquote liberal who are actually
far left and then conservatives are
adopting liberal positions so
conservatives saying something like well
if it's your flag you can burn it
whereas conservatives used to say you
shouldn't be allowed to burn the flag
Trump and many of the Trump supporters
still said you should not be allowed to
desecrate the flag but a lot of
conservatives are adopting more
libertarian positions or classically
liberal positions and I think that's one
of the intentions of the left is to
force conservatives leftward right so
they make the wheel rotate the far left
becomes moderate and conservatives
become Fringe then people who are center
right are now the far right and they
keep turning the wheel until the left is
considered moderate well I would argue
even school choice is liberal you're
saying people should have the ability to
choose that we should be able to let
parents make that decision on their own
and they're saying no no it has to be
our way you have to have kids in school
in the schools we choose even if the
schools totally failing the child they
must stay there we don't care what you
want for your kid and we don't care if
you want to have a future or an
education or opportunity we you must do
what we say that is not that that is not
a liberal
attitude is that you you have to conform
no I mean it's it's the idea that
liberalism or the idea the ideals of
liberalism have fallen so out of favor
with you know specifically young people
um but I think there's too many of the
thought leaders that have been writing
books and papers and stuff for the past
30 years and influencing the teachers
and influencing the schools of Education
that's why you have kids that don't
understand you know that don't
understand anything about our our system
people don't understand the way that the
why you know things like freedom of
speech and stuff are important so I I
you know I don't they're they're they're
they're cutting our our this country's
youth from the history as you mentioned
they don't know history and then you see
there was this teacher who said
something about wokeness in the schools
so the students went out and protested
the teacher with communist Sons yeah and
this is how it starts people need to pay
attention to this because those kids in
10 20 years are going to be in politics
there is a maoist cultural revolution
going on in America right now but people
think because it doesn't happen
overnight it doesn't happen but it's
never overnight yeah I think something
that we recently spoke to someone who
was in she had she moved from China when
she was in her 20s and she'd gone
through the Revolution and she said they
started with the kids what they did was
they went to the kids and they got them
to believe and then the kids would turn
in the parents for wrong think and you
can see that already you see families
breaking up over cultural issues over
political issues in the United States
and you could see that next step of
children willing to go to the government
and say my parents are thinking the
wrong thing you need to go after them
you can present evidence and people will
still reject that I've been doing this
like been saying look this stuff and
blah blah blah and talking about that
stuff with my friends that are that are
historically liberals right Democrats
like I come from the music entertainment
world and so there's tons of producers
and and record Executives and and people
in bands and stuff that I'm familiar
with and most of them are basic
basically the default Democrat right and
they aren't aware that this is going on
and then you can show them and present
evidence and see look these are the
parallels to what went on in China when
the cultural revolution was getting
started and here Etc you can see this
and and they just refuse to believe it
because there's because it doesn't have
that like immediate happening right in
front of me right now that they expect
to get that they expect to see with a
revolution they don't realize that it's
a slow rolling kind of thing and trying
to convince them is incredibly hard it
took me or it took the uh the Bill Maher
and I think it was it wasn't the Elon
Musk thing it was Bill Maher talking
about his experience with or what he saw
the parallels between maoism and and the
woke on college campuses now when that
came out then a buddy of mine was like
yeah okay I can kind of see that but it
took it takes so much it takes someone
like Bill Maher who's
basically a you know an s-lib and and
saying that kind of stuff limousine
liberals yeah you know it takes him to
kind of be like no
this is actually happening and I see the
parallels too thankfully he said it
because that is actually going to wake
up your typical liberals your default
Democrats because that's someone they
trust telling them that as opposed to
someone they don't trust telling them
that but I don't know that you know I
don't know that it has translated to
something where most people feel that
way I think one of the big ones that
wakes a lot of people up is when they
get called out for saying a woman is a
female or like we shouldn't have males
and female sports there are some really
obvious ones that you can't ignore are
obviously insane and like for me having
it affect my life and seeing it impact
other people's lives I know a lot of
women who were very much so on the left
and then saw this happen and were like
nope not anymore there's a line I mean I
really do feel like the left pushes
further and further until finally the
bubble pops but for the most part they
keep it to a certain point where it
stays loving and that's the thing they
believe people believe it's loving you
know this is a kind way to do things
like everybody benefits from this we you
know everybody benefits if you don't let
people say hateful things that's what
they believe you know and then they say
it's hateful to say something like the
scientific research coming out of Europe
suggests that we should not be giving
children sex change surgery they say
that's hate speech it's like it's just
what that's what they're doing in Europe
I don't know you know I mean it was the
same thing with kids learning with masks
on Europe much earlier came out and said
we have to make sure that kids are
learning to speak that the speech is is
very clear that we can and and these
scientific studies came out but then you
know it was like we we weren't allowed
to say that I mean there are all these
things that as studies come out from
other countries we're slower to adopt
that thinking so that's very interesting
yeah but I think your average person is
like oh no hate speech good we shouldn't
be throwing slurs around but it's
playing out to a much more extreme way
this is what they do they will say
something like we just it's the modern
Bailey we're just saying that people
shouldn't be using slurs and then
everyone goes well we agree with that
then you come out you say something like
I have concerns about whether or not we
should be sterilizing children up hate
speech that's what we've been right and
so these default Libs who don't pay
attention I don't know what's going on
have no idea what they're actually
getting behind is like overt communism
I I think that you also have a bunch of
people who don't understand what
sterilization is I think that you have a
lot of people that truly don't probably
have never been through a surgery
probably don't know what it's like to go
into the hospital don't know what the
after effects are of going through
something like this and so they look at
the people who are saying we've got to
keep kids safe and say how can you rob
children of this opportunity
probably a lot of those people will
never be in the situation of even having
a child that is considering this or but
I I will tell you that I've noticed that
friends who have been wildly liberal
about this stuff and have been very
supportive of these surgeries when their
own child has come to them and said I've
decided that I'm the opposite gender
it's a different reaction they get mad
or they're like
this is not happening to us you know
this is not you this is not I mean in
some cases I've seen both I've seen
where it almost feels like the parent
pushed them into it and I've seen where
you have a a strong Christian or Jewish
community and then suddenly this social
contagion comes through and the parents
like wait a minute but you were the ones
talking to your kids about being this is
acceptable we love this and this is
great and they're talking to kids that
are way too young to understand what
this means and we've seen this new
phenomena where kids see this on social
media and they're looking all kids are
looking for a place to belong they're
looking for a place to stand out they're
looking for a place to get attention
that's what kids are and so these people
are getting a lot of attention this must
be where I belong and then Mom and Dad
don't know how to handle it because
you've got so many pressures on you to
say that this is okay no it's not okay I
mean that's that's the benefit of not
being a liberal I don't have to be like
uh I've I've heard stories where I read
one story online where it was a mother
who said that she was totally in favor
of all of this she was cheering it on
she was going to the rallies of the
parades and then when her kid came to
her and said that he was trans they were
like no you're not and then all of a
sudden they went uh oh
the the reaction that they got from the
schools where everybody was don't be a
bigot and they were like but we know our
kid our kid was never experiencing any
of these symptoms is now just saying
these things and without any symptoms
the school is saying it's true and
that's what woke them up to hey this
thing is it's something else something
else one of the phenomenon that or or
another parallel to what was going on
with the cultural evolution in China and
today was you had red and black
identities in China if you had a red
identity you were accepted as
politically correct you might have been
a socialist maybe someday you were going
to go on and become an actual member of
the Communist Party
um and so that was one of the ways that
they segregated each other
um here in the U.S now if you are a CIS
a normal white person that is not that
doesn't have any kind of
um LGBT identity you are looked at as
suspect because you possibly could be a
republican yeah you might be so
automatically just by year just by not
having any kind of protective identity
you are suspected of being the other the
bad guy and there is a way out you can
just take on any type of LGBT identity
you can be non-binary you can be some
type of polyamorous or whatever any kind
of thing that you want to take on that
gives you an LGBT identity protects you
from being accused as of being the bad
person and it's the same thing that
happened in China it is it is not new
and if I wish that more people would
recognize this and and I think that if
they did they'd be scared as crap that
was like the beginning of the social
credit score in China and now we're
seeing that in the United States and you
know I think it's funny because people
say well why don't more people run for
office and I just look at what it was
like to run run for office you know
because that's like the major social
credit score right I'm like I don't know
if I want to order for my Starbucks app
because my name is on it you know I
don't know what people will do when I go
in and I mean it is true that if you are
known for something and when does it
come to when do we get to the point
where someone walks up to you with their
cell phone and looks at you and goes
okay no they don't pass their their
social credit score is too low or the
bank looks at you and says no this
person they don't pass I mean we're
getting there I'm confident that that
has happened already it has just not
been exposed yes I agree
it it starts with
we have the ESG stuff which is behind
the scenes companies not wanting to
allow certain behaviors because it could
affect their ESG rating or whatever
Michael Knowles had this big Twitter
Thread about Anheuser-Busch that
basically they're wrapped up in this so
they'll never back down they can't back
down well okay then we need to stop
buying their products and then hopefully
this Panic just keeps dragging them down
I think with the H with HSBC downgrading
their stock that may be
that may that may that may be a a
Cascade effect but I'm also thinking
about it in terms of you know this this
new Industrial Revolution and what work
really means and how many people there
are in big cities who do literally
nothing no work nothing and they make a
lot of money
I'm comparing somebody who's a Tradesman
to somebody who wrote for BuzzFeed news
the person writing for BuzzFeed news did
not create anything of Merit or value to
Human Society but was getting paid a lot
more than say an apprentice Tradesman or
something like that someone was actually
building things and fixing things so
right there you already have the makings
of social credit the fact that you are a
New Yorker of high social status the
credit was already there and it's simply
money money being given to you for no
real reason
and then you can buy things and have
access to things I was thinking about
this a few weeks ago I don't know if
social credit is going to be what people
think it is that you'll pull up a phone
and you'll look at the app and you'll
say a 200 oh wow you know you're you're
up there oh a seven oh yeah no no it's
gonna be money people who worked for
BuzzFeed news and vice were getting
money for being good socially upstanding
citizens they were working for these
companies and writing woke propaganda
and getting paid a lot of money to do it
getting paid more money to write woke
propaganda than to fix a toilet we need
toilets we don't need woke propaganda
the party needs woke propaganda and you
are rewarded heavily with big money as
we enter this new this new Industrial
Revolution
the jobs you get are the social credit
score we are not going to need Farm
hands when we automate these jobs so
what's going to happen is the job you
get the company will get financing for
ESG the banks are going to be like
you're very woke here's financing
they'll then hire you and say we want
you to make big signs saying go
communism and you'll get paid 100 Grand
a year to do it then someone else of low
social standing who makes burgers for
instance they get less money you don't
need to have that score attached
somebody then I wonder how it is that
people can walk into these nightclubs
and just throw money around like crazy
like what job do they have I thought
about this at casinos how could there be
a guy at the craps table with three
grand like what job does he have he must
have a really powerful important job
in the future it's not going to be what
important job do you have because we're
Auto automating away a lot of the labor
it's going to be how have you helped ESG
and then you're gonna get cash
net cash Grant you the excess yep
digital Gulag and cbdc's backing the
system so one extra security layer for
it is I don't need to assign a score to
you I just need to make sure you get
money for supporting the the the far
left cause how many people worked at
Twitter that got fired and Twitter
functions essentially the same and
actually they're changing things you
know and that's exactly it they're
getting paid ridiculous sums of money to
live in San Francisco
because they're propagandists for the
machine that is your paycheck was your
social credit score if we are not tying
labor to I'm sorry uh your your income
to your labor anymore it literally used
to be like I bake bread I get paid and
we value that that was Merit Merit is
becoming your social standing look at
Instagram look at Twitter look at Tick
Tock your social status Dylan Mulvaney
produces nothing for the society but
probably makes a lot of money
Dylan Mulvaney then the combination of
social currency big following and hard
currency for while producing nothing of
value means that Del mulvani can walk
into the White House and you can't
that's social credit right there but
also a very depressed Society because
think about what those people are really
like I mean I think Dylan Mulvaney is
genuinely depressed we keep hearing that
you know he struggled a lot or she
struggled a lot since all of this has
happened you know this is all a big
problem but it's the same with the
people it's the same with these
reporters that are these woke reporters
that are writing they they're very
depressed I mean you read the articles
what they just put an article out in
Michigan saying these reporters these
young reporters go through so much harm
and stress over having to write these
stories and then one guy says I couldn't
even I was okay with it not even being
true because it was so stressful for me
I'm like whoa but that's exactly what
you're saying they're making a lot of
money to put the message out it doesn't
matter if they're doing a good job job
they are putting the message out but
they're living miserable lives so they
may be getting a lot of money but
they're miserable what kind of a society
is that so it's a very dark one so this
is what they're trying to do they don't
want shows like this to exist because we
do very well here at timcast the daily
wire does very well and voting with your
dolls has always been a thing so
currency being some kind of social
credit has always existed but as we get
into
as we're fighting a culture war and as
we're moving into an information economy
and influencer economy this is why the
left has organized to go after sponsors
because then they can remove you from
the system and strip you of your Social
credit standing
it's all about influence you have an
Instagram account you're a pro
skateboarder let's say you got a hundred
thousand followers you have sponsors
every time you post a picture of you
drinking their sports drink you get paid
200 bucks
someone then starts emailing that
company and says cut them off take away
their funds you're only allowed to
support our political cause if we lose
that fight you are in full-blown
communist social credit score system yep
and that's that's the goal I I really
don't think that there's uh a whole lot
of convincing argument that that would
be able to make me think of anything
different now the the technology that we
have like we talked a little bit about
fintech the technology that we have
available to us now and the convenience
that people have gotten used to the
ability to just use your phone to do
stuff like that they're gonna make being
in the in the digital Gulag so
convenient and so comfortable that it's
gonna actually it's gonna be so alluring
and no and very few people are going to
say no I don't want to be in the you
know inside it's going to be something
that is
I mean I wonder if there will be very if
there will be anybody that would really
choose to be outside of it other than
people that are like old there would be
some Millennials maybe some gen xers
that would say no but anyone that that
hasn't been born yet or anyone that's an
infant or under five years old now they
will have they will never have known
life outside of it and the idea of
living like those old people it'll be
like the idea of living the Stone Age
you with with AI technology where it's
at with VR technology and the neural
link chip and metaverse stuff I mean
metaverse I think is like crumbling
apart but digital digital worlds
no one's going to want to live in
reality yep you're gonna you're gonna
click the Nora link into your chip into
your port on your neck your eyes whirl
back in your head you enter this Matrix
Universe where you where you as a god of
your own reality just say generate me a
world where I'm the Dragon Warrior and
I'm Gonna Save The Princess and then it
just manifests right before your eyes
and you say I'm gonna live here instead
it's like Westworld yeah yep you get to
live in your fantasy where you can do
whatever you want why would anyone want
to leave the worlds that people are
going to create are going to be the most
horrific monstrosity because there's no
repercussions you're gonna you're gonna
have the most insane deviant crazy
self-indulgent
monstrous like it's gonna be over two
years ago because you can experience
anything you want and if reality sucks
that's gonna be more appealing oh oh no
it's gonna it's they're gonna be worse
because people are gonna be like Oh you
mean I can chop bodies up and have and
experience that and not have any kind of
remember vacations it is called it's
called GTA yeah exactly the fact that
Grand Theft Auto has a video game has
been so popular for several decades
everybody everybody has gotten the
hooker then beaten her to death and
taken the money back like that was the
joke in GTA you go you get the hooker
you go behind the thing you beat you and
so you know yes
I have never played but I have I you
know when I was in college all my
friends would take me in and show me
exactly that but it's true everybody's
like look at this you can't say I'm not
right
GTA got better and better and one of my
favorite things was if you're playing
Grand Theft Auto you can aggress upon a
pedestrian in any way that's why I'm not
saying like straight I'm saying like any
any way to make that person want to
fight you and as soon as they start
chasing you you can call the police on
your phone when the cops pull up as soon
as that other person hits you the cops
arrest that person so there's a there's
a lot of really interesting Dynamics in
Grand Theft Auto to make it fun mostly
in the past few years people have been
playing online that's what they've been
it's mostly just player versus player
mini games and stuff like that but when
we get to the point where you can put on
a headset or plug yourself into the
neuralink neural Link's gonna change the
game when we can do read write brain
computer interface and someone can plug
a cable into your brain to give you an
experience and you can actually feel in
these universes no one will ever leave
yup why why would any nobody I don't
know I cannot I get that but I also
think that there is something so amazing
about life that is really hard to give
up that nature that ability to carry a
child nurture a child I think it's
parenting I mean maybe it will become
uncool and it will go away but I just
can't imagine that you will give that up
come on here's what was going to happen
you're going to apply the women yeah
you're going to apply for a job and
they're gonna say great when can you
start and you say I can start first
thing Monday morning I'm like amazing
and what's your your neural Link contact
and you're gonna say I I don't use
neuralink and they're gonna say well all
of our meetings are in the metaverse you
you have to have a norling contact and
well I guess I'll get one and that's how
they get you like I think a lot of
people will be inspired to start their
own thing like even with small
scholarships and stuff we see companies
like daily wire sponsor themselves Tim
cast sponsor themselves with Casper
group coffee yes but like cell phones we
just all did it you're everybody said
you've got to have a cell phone how am I
supposed to get in touch with you and we
said okay we'll get one and people I
remember saying I'm not going to have a
CIA tracking device in my pocket now
everyone's like which CIA tracking
device did you get and they get the
Apple One or the Android one and there's
something else you guys that I want to
go push or go back to what you had said
about talking about the experience like
women wouldn't do this and Etc that is
all garbage all right the reason that's
all garbage is because your whole
universe is in between your ears so once
neuralink can figure out how to produce
the experience
it's over
it doesn't because the experience by the
time that happens a person's gonna be a
few years I mean I don't know about read
write to a brain that could be a long
way off we are already at the point
where neuralink can read brain signals
yeah and so uh um and they've and I
thought this was going to be used for
good things like people that can't walk
that's where we're at right now and I do
think it's fantastic they can connect
nerves and give people the ability to
walk or they can do uh like those
robotical eggs so you can use your mind
to move them and you can walk again
they're just gonna make walking
unnecessary
that's true and we're right now where
are we all Wally's yes
or you won't even need the headset you
just press a button on the side of your
head Wally got this wrong in Wally
everybody was morbidly obese floating
around in chairs it's really funny how
when we look back in time like um
Demolition Man you ever see that movie
no with Sylvester Stallone and Wesley
Snipes I think it was right
yeah so it's he's a cop and he gets uh
Frozen for like 30 years or something
goes to the Future because he he they
frame him for a crime or something I
don't know I can't remember the story
but uh he's in the future and phone
booths are Video Phone booths isn't it
really funny that back then it was like
the 90s they made this movie and they're
like what will phone booths be like in
30 years like they'll have cameras in
them we got rid of them all in like the
year two in like 2005 we started getting
rid of phone booths and everyone got
cell phones by 2007 everybody had a cell
phone we could not predict how it was
going to play out so right now you you
get Wally where they're like in the
future everyone's gonna be in Hover
chairs eating and morbidly obese with no
bones because they don't have to do
anything uh and and no I think you're
right no one's gonna need to walk at all
we're already the point where you can
load up mid-journey and and type in
something like
well here's what I like doing if you use
mid Journey here's my advice
if you want a photograph you type in the
photograph and then put Getty
photography because what what it what it
does is it's trained off the internet so
all the captions for photos that look
real will say Getty photography or
something of that nature or AP news so
if you type in Donald Trump eating ice
cream Getty photography it will simulate
a Getty photograph Donald Trump
instantly you can make these things I
typed in last night Donald Trump going
Super Saiyan and got a cartoon of a
super ripped Donald Trump glowing with
energy and spiky hair I did uh Joe Biden
super ripped and got Aviator Joe Biden
all ripped flexing with the glasses on
we can do that in an instant so that
means we are a couple years away from
being able to render a full video where
you're like make me a three minute video
of Donald Trump doing a series of
backflips on the on a gym mat and it
will render it so what's stopping you
from creating some video of a politician
that says something terrible and
changing the course of the world nothing
we can already do it with audio I I we
there's 11 Labs we I can pull it up
right now and simulate the voices of
several prominent personalities because
we've done it to prove a point I can I
can literally you know what let's let's
uh but that's the danger of having
someone like Joe Biden as president
because you never know what the people
around him would create and he has no
idea there is only the people around him
are there any laws about the AI voice
that's why they're trying to put they're
trying to make laws around this and and
what was it Italy that just made it
illegal was it Italy that just made AI
illegal I think so and and so I mean
think about it because if you have this
Manchurian Candidate if you have this
guy who really is not in there at all
and you can create something and send it
to Putin or you could send it to you
know president XI and you could create a
world war or something I don't know who
knows let's let's give this one a shot
who are you doing Tudor Dixon is
fantastic I think everyone should listen
to her podcast this is Tucker Carlson
thank you and good night it's pretty
good I just typed that out right now
that's true but did he not actually say
that you did not say that
sure he said it
because the computer doesn't know proper
pacing it's just text but you can do
tricks with commas and periods and
capitalization to make to and then
re-render it until you get the proper
inflection or
you can actually just do a couple words
at a time and then edit them together
there was a viral video of Joe Rogan
selling um
what's it called male enhancement and it
was completely fake someone AI generated
this stuff it's already happening so if
we're at that point
with virtual reality headsets we are a
few years away from you being able to
put on the headset and say uh Oculus
render me a universe a video game where
I get to be a street fighter in Street
Fighter 2 and then it will just make it
it will make that game instantly for you
and you'll be like oh cool I'm I'm Ryu
and I'm gonna do a Hadouken
who's going to want to go outside
when you can have literally already
people get addicted to Mid Journey the
AI image generator because it's so much
fun but so I will I will fight back on
one I know you're like no stop talking I
got you too but what about what about
okay movies where Earth is gone right
they're in space they always long for
Earth they always want to go out and be
in the grass and see the birds and I
believe there's people that will always
want to get virtue have you seen the
have you seen the picture where they put
the VR goggles on the cow
but you can't smell the cow
no they gave a cow a cow virtual reality
goggles to make it think it was in a
beautiful lush green field with the sun
shining to get it to produce more yeah
make more milk look I mean I know I had
no idea I know I'm the black pill guy on
this one but the thing is like I said
everything you experience happens
between your ears your whole world all
the things that you think that you
experience in the real world they're not
they're in here and there is a real
world that we can come in contact you're
selling this pardon me you're selling
this I know you're like involved
this
it's not something that I'm happy about
but the truth of the matter is the the
way that we experience the world is in
our heads like we come into contact with
things and like without that's why you
can have Phantom pains and stuff like
that people lose a limb they can still
feel the pain because the experience
isn't in the limb the experience is in
your head if they can plug into your
head and make things it is and there is
a human experience I believe that cannot
be given up what about the the wife who
wakes up the moment her husband dies in
battle what about the the mother who
kills I don't have any ability to
explain things that are Supernatural I I
do we're all already in the metaverse
that just makes God this is like the
main thing if you're actually networked
in it makes sense then that when someone
dies you're like whoa because the
connection gets severed it's like
Network signal lost you know what I mean
no no it's your heart maybe I'm Tupac
I think you're right and I think people
will simulate it I think what they're
gonna do is people we're already at a
point where young men are not having
relationships more and more and more
young men are increasingly getting older
without having any kind of relationship
and I'll I'll keep it that simple
so what's going to happen they're going
to go to them and say put on these
goggles and meet your virtual girlfriend
they've already got virtual girlfriend
apps where you can text why do you think
it is that more men aren't having
relationships
well doesn't that mean more women aren't
either how does that work so they're
just all becoming lesbians no no what's
happening is that younger women are uh
fewer guys are getting more women
several different things have happened
older guys with access to the internet
will date several women women are being
told they're sexually liberated and to
sleep around so what ends up happening
is a small percentage of men get a high
percentage of women and it's inverted
for women so women are being liberated
but a woman might hook up with a small
handful of guys whereas the guy hooks up
with a few dozen women so it's like the
top whatever person I think it is I I
don't know I guess if you I still have
hope in a lot of women that they're
looking for somebody I know I think that
women are getting tricked I think that's
the thing the women are and I believe
that the women who have been convinced
that you know sex is liberating and all
that sex is emotional and I believe that
it is every relationship affects you
deeply in your inner soul and and people
are being lied to and so I think it's
becoming a very depressed Society
although I believe that men that are
listening to this are the ones that are
following in the player player category
are like yeah that's me I'm getting all
the chicks
other guys are really sad and they're
getting and so there was a data that
came out from dating apps that found
it's something like the bell curve for
women is 20 of men they asked women like
rate these men on their attractiveness
and women said basically 80 percent of
men were below average and only rated
the highest attractive guys as like it's
something like that for how the data
worked the the bell curve for men on
whether or not they rated a woman is
attractive was a standard bell curve so
it's like these women are unattractive
average is pretty good and then wow
these women are super attractive women
were like all these guys are ugly except
these guys
but the issue then is you combine that
with modern sexual Liberation feminism
and women are being told you don't have
to be in a relationship you don't have
to expect anything from the guy and the
guys are like wow it's free I'll take it
and so the top tier guys who are
physically fit attractive and well-off
are gonna go on a date they're gonna
hook up with a woman and then be like
we'll do this again and then he
immediately goes in the app and says
next
young men are getting dejected so what
my point with all this was they then go
to those young men and say meet your new
girlfriend put your headset on
and this is putting the cow in the VR
headset to make it think it's in a lush
green field there wasn't there's an app
I think it was replica was that where
guys are dating these AI text Bots
because they're lonely and then the
creator of it took away the dating
function because they were like okay
this is getting a little weird and the
users revolted they were like no my
girlfriend's like okay we're gonna give
it back to you but your grandfather
didn't We're not gonna let anyone else
do this because it's getting weird
that's where we're going so it's like
the other options nothing so I'll have
an AI girlfriend and that's only on your
phone like that is the most that is not
immersive that is not an experience like
that's not plugging your head in and
getting you know dopamine and and the
the response uh drugs pumped directly
into your brain this is what it's
getting weird man yeah the version of
what's that movie Lars and the Real
Girls yeah this and like there's I saw
the chat getting all worked up this is
not an endorsement of me saying that
this is something I like I'm saying this
is the reality that we need to prepare
for now because these Technologies are
coming whether we like it or not because
even if the US doesn't know what China's
gonna do so they're going to get people
to join the Matrix because you're gonna
get a lot of dejected young men who
can't get relationships and who are
lonely
but there's another way they're going to
get people
they're going to get people who have bad
breakups and who are depressed and
desperately in love with the person who
left them or
somebody whose loved one dies
well the AIS has like one division you
recreate yep check this out they've
already done this they've taken
someone's Facebook profile everything
they've ever written and turned it into
a chat bot so you can talk to your dead
dad and be like hey Dad remember we did
this yeah it was a great evening on
February 17th I remember that day like
it was yeah you were out they know the
speech patterns and they know all the
memories that's that's weird that's
twisted your your dad dies you turn you
put on the VR and say user profile John
Smith
Chicago you know Chicago Illinois age 73
deceased this date generate and then
boom you're in Chicago hanging out with
your dad and he's like it's good to see
you again and you crying finally get to
talk to your dad again or your mom or
your husband or your wife or your kids
but they're not them no but people are
not need that but people
who are grieving and like they're gonna
say plug me in
oh I can see that that could happen but
that's so dangerous what a terrible path
to go down not dangerous not dangerous
for the people who want to control the
systems and and control what people do
it's the perfect thing for them
but how do you function as a society so
who's making I mean stuff to eat you
still have to have robots
you're gonna have robots do whatever I
mean that is so far off well they're
also telling people to abort their kids
and already a lot of food production is
automated we have big machines doing
most of the work two did you ever you
ever hear the phrase fully automated
luxury communism
that's exactly what people are looking
for so not only is what we're talking
about definitely on the horizon there
are people that are excited for it to
arrive and want to do everything they
can to expedite its arrival fully
automated luxury communism there are
people that don't want to do anything
other than be plugged into the Matrix
and be ha and and be pumped full of the
feel-good drugs because existence itself
leads to suffering so that's so because
that's the truth this is where I mean we
talk about having a mental health crisis
in the country or across the globe is
this what happens then the next step is
to make everybody feel better by having
a fake world
well
people are going to choose it
because it feels good
right so are you familiar with fermi's
Paradox this is a it's an idea that
represents if the universe is so big and
life exists why have we not encountered
alien life that's the question and
there's a bunch of potential Solutions
some are that any sufficiently advanced
civilization will blow itself up like
we've developed nuclear weapons and
other crazy things I happen to think
that one of the strongest contenders as
to why we have not met aliens well for
one maybe there aren't any I don't know
but it could be that
any humans have needs and desires we
need those things to function we have
emotions those things help us survive we
get scared we feel strong connections
and so our if you do a good thing and
accomplish a goal it feels good that's
why video games are so addictive
I think the thing is
most life if it does exist is going to
chase after whatever it is that gives it
a reward
so what are we going to do we're gonna
make video games we are going to make
video games that give us the reward now
there's drugs you can take that give you
rewards opium right heroin or whatever
opiates they trigger that good euphoric
feeling in your brain and you just
people melt away in it and then die what
we're going to make is
when you get a dopamine hit from
accomplishing something when you feel
strongly connected to a loved one we are
going to simulate that so you feel good
all the time and it is the same thing as
any drug and then instead of traveling
the stars and colonizing new worlds
we're all going to lay down in the Pod
eat the bugs put on the headset and be
happy
now y'all might be saying like that
would make me happy sure but your kids
will your kids are going to grow up in
this world with this available to them
and you're gonna say I don't want my kid
using neural link but then when they're
in school they're gonna be like well how
else are they supposed to learn our
whole curriculum is through neuralink
you weirdo homeschoolers and there'll be
holdouts there will be and they'll raise
their kids the right way but how many
conservative parents right now knowing
everything going on are still putting
their kids in public schools saying well
what am I supposed to do I have to work
I can't get my kid out of school yes in
20 years you'll say the exact same thing
what am I supposed to I'm at work you
know I disagree with what they're doing
but my kid uses neuralink while your
kid's in the neuraling they're
generating that addiction that
connection and then they're going to be
in their 20s they're going to be like no
time for you Dad plug me in
and they're gonna become the Dragon
Warrior or a carrot or something who
knows I mean it's essentially what we
watch with Avatar
and well worse than that I mean Avatar
at the very least you are still in the
real world you know well yes to to an
extent but I mean you're still in a body
that's not yours but it's still just
your mind in that world but some of
these virtual universes people might
just be a carrot like the people will
identify as crazy things someone might
be like I'm I'm a rabbit kin that
there's there's have you ever heard of
uh of other kin
basically trans mythical species so it's
people who think they're trans mythical
species they're a human they're they're
like an elf Mage born in a human body or
they're a dragon born no joke I just
it's like so bizarre so they're gonna be
in the metaverse and they're gonna be
like only in this reality am I my true
self The Dragon King volsenak flying
around the Mystic eight kingdoms
fighting the demons from the nether
realm and and you and you're gonna be
like this is that not real life but
they're they're gonna think to
themselves do I want to work at
McDonald's or be the Dragon Emperor of
the eight Realms Dragon Emperor dude and
they're gonna plug in they're already
doing it people already do this in video
games you know there there are people
who you ask them like what have you done
with your life and they'll say
you know I'm a high I'm a top 10 PVP
World of Warcraft whatever and it's like
that's really great I mean but if you're
in Esports you might make money doing
that no joke right but some people
dedicate their lives to just being a cog
in the game and not really being the
best person at it and they're not
generating any skill but I mean I'll add
on to that I'll add a layer to that when
we're at the point where our society
says you can be rich and famous for
being good at playing a video game we
are entering the point where we are
eliminating true labor from the
capitalist Market
people are famous now for just posting
pictures of themselves on Instagram
people are making money
by posting pictures on Instagram that
money is then used to travel the world
and do whatever they want
if that's the case
you don't have to do work anymore that's
not work we're calling it work it's
something I mean it's not it's not easy
to make make a living you're still doing
some work but I'm gonna be honest it is
this job that I do here
one million fold easier than tilling a
field and growing crops
that's why I'm here because I don't like
if it was easier to grow crops and work
a farm I'd be doing that but this is
easier so we're really getting to the
point where
sitting around complaining on the
Internet is more lucrative and easier
and we call it work most of the people
posting pictures for money aren't they
doing it as advertisements
yeah so that's kind of a job
you're you're doing it to get eyeballs
to get it to attract influence and then
sell a product of some sort and then
people so there there's a large portion
of the economy that's turning into the
it's the influencer economy it's an
information economy but that is also I
mean I think that we've seen a lot of
people who have done that and become
very self-obsessed you know
self-important so then once that starts
to fade when the likes aren't coming
then that is also a depressed Society I
mean it's then they plug themselves into
the neural link and they go back to the
world where everyone loves them or like
if you're not the beautiful influencer
forever like have you lost value gosh
you know I so I come from the the world
of a steel foundry which is a very hard
labor job you know you you are making
product and there's just so much pride
in that you know you make a product it
does things it goes out into the world
it makes it makes trucks move it makes
tractors move it makes people you know
people are able to get products because
of that I mean what how can that go away
people grew up making things that makes
them feel good they were they were
taught they looked up to their parents
they looked up to the prominent members
of their society who were doing these
things and it makes them feel good to
fit in
but now to fit in you got to get
followers on social media so they did
that we talked about this poll where
they asked American Kids what do you
want to be when you grew up and most of
them said like a YouTuber I think it was
YouTuber right
Chinese kids were asked they said
astronaut
what is what does being a YouTuber mean
for me it means complaining on the
internet like I really like I think
there's value in it because we're
fighting a culture where we're trying to
keep people focused on the foundations
of this country and what it means to
make a system function
but at the same time I'm like how do I
make more money than a dude who actually
like builds houses
you know that's crazy to me
yeah it's the influencer economy and
people want to be influencers this is
why you hear so many people standing up
and saying AI is the most dangerous
thing that can happen to the world I
mean like what was the guy that just
stepped down from Google or who they
came out and said AI is the most
dangerous thing that can happen to the
world I mean this is why I think it is
Italy that is Banning it right now and
this is why we I mean now I'm rethinking
my answer to your question of running
for office again it's like well who's
going to do it you know who's going to
save us from this I want people to have
families and stay like run in the grass
I mean those are
I'll I'll I'm gonna pull up the story
with this from The New York Times The
Godfather of AI leaves Google in warns
of danger ahead for half a century
Jeffrey Hinton nurtured the technology
at the heart of chatbots like chat GPT
now he worries it will cause serious
harm
he officially joined a growing chorus of
Critics on Monday who say the companies
are racing towards danger he said he
quit his job at Google where he worked
for more than a decade quote I console
myself with a normal excuse if I hadn't
done it somebody else would have that's
amazing there's they they gave chat GPT
access to the internet access to its own
code and money
and it immediately tried seeking power
and deceiving people
one of the things that it did to bypass
captcha was it contacted a a disabled
assistance hotline and said you sent a
message saying I'm blind and I need to
log in can you tell me what this says
and they're like yep sure no problem
here you go and the AI tricked a human
into giving it access to a system
chew on that one
I think I think the AIS I think it
already took over like I don't think
there's anything there's any style I
don't think the law is going to stop it
the there is I the worst thing that I
have heard about uh AGI artificial
general intelligence is the concept that
if it is capable of strategy whoever
develops AGI whatever country develops
AGI first automatically wins the any
kind of war that you could possibly come
up with because just like with deep blue
like now that deep blue exists human
beings can are no longer capable of
beating the most advanced chess
algorithms so because people can't
because AGI is that powerful there is an
incentive to have a first strike
if we ban it
China does it and they're probably
already doing it
well I mean don't you think that there's
the ability for it to be researched and
still understood and not what I really
think is the orange man is very bad and
these are the things that are important
to talk about that was the CNN thing
last night we got taught we're talking
about AGI here and the possibility of
nuclear war and stuff and and they're
just it's just so damn frustrating to
think about that sorry
but I think that
they control people through messages
like that I mean they're very powerful
with messages like that and they're
they're very powerful shaming you and
telling you that it's loving to be with
them I mean that's what I'm saying they
frame things incredibly well so they
don't have to talk about this they don't
want you to think about this
I mean it's not a lovely thing to think
about you're like gloating over there
I'm not gloating it's just it's it's one
of those things where it's like it's
it's a real these are real threats and
these are real things that are going on
and these conversations have to be had
right yeah there aren't enough people
having them they're already replacing
jobs with AI like only fans they're fun
oh yeah uh fake pictures and it's like
probably dudes running the account so I
noticed it's already well then you can't
be a famous instagramer or you can't
fans person you could be anyone two big
things one on Instagram a lot of young
women make money off being influencers
by just posting photos of themselves but
now you can AI generate a character and
have it automatically post three
pictures per day you walk away and it's
generating influence and attention the
other thing that's happened is deep fake
porn where you can take anyone's face
and put it on a woman's body or man's
body and it generates the video for you
it was a huge Scandal I guess on Twitch
or something like that people are doing
weird things with it well that's
happened with a bunch of celebrities
right there it's it's like the Futurama
episode where Fry downloads Lucy Liu
into a mannequin into a robot so that he
can be dating Lucy Liu like that's
really where we're kind of going with it
with the AI and all this stuff I mean if
if if you are capable of creating your
own AI girlfriend why wouldn't you make
it look like your favorite actor or your
favorite actress or whatever or you mix
wouldn't you make a bunch of money off
of her on the internet yeah well here's
the thing too Weird Science morals we're
talking about all this domestic stuff
but let's talk about little things let's
talk about war yeah what happens if this
AI is Unleashed into the US internet
let's say Russia or China or whoever
Builds an AI that can automatically
create social media accounts and
simulate real human behavior on Twitter
10 years ago the U.S Air Force was outed
for creating fake Twitter I think it was
Twitter accounts to influence politics
in other countries they're called sock
puppets one person controls 50 accounts
and they'll you'll tweet something like
well I just think you know taxes are too
high and then they'll say are you nuts
taxes are not high enough the rich
people need to be taxed and they'll log
into next account I agree with him
there's not enough taxes log into the
next account yes you're both right taxes
should be higher one person doing all
that now we have an AI do it and they've
probably been doing this for the past
several years now they can press go and
have an AI and a thousand responses to
your one tweet you might think you're
famous
like Dylan Mulvaney that's just an
algorithm propping up Dylan Mulvaney's
post so Dylan thinks there's people out
there who love me Bud Light proves most
people find Del mulvedi grading and and
and and just unpersonable I'll keep up
keep it a little nice but because Tick
Tock is propping up these videos and
making people watch it or I'm willing to
bet some of them aren't even real people
Dylan is convinced they're doing
something good
like this is what they should keep doing
meanwhile you can see
Bud Light was destroyed because of their
association with with Dylan mulvania I
think I think the AI attacks
weaponization is going to destroy
Society like some kind of mind plague
that comes in and no one sees it coming
or we do see it coming we can't stop it
oh how did you stop it that's the thing
like that's where I'm at it's like
that's why it's kind of like well that's
why I'm fairly black build on it is I
can't conceive of any way to stop it
because it plays to what people want
like it knows exactly how to deliver
dopamine right to your brain you know
and if if if just a like button and just
a notification hey someone liked
something that you said if that can
affect your behavior so much like that
just that small little thing never mind
a plug right into your brain that can
control your your your uh your dopamine
delivery system come on you like human
beings cannot fight that like there is
no way it's hard because I mean I know
what it was like when I was trying to
quit smoking cigarettes right
nicotineism like it is a it is
incredibly powerful I can't imagine what
just constantly dumping dopamine
straight into your head like every time
you think the proper thought the
algorithm says look give them a little
papadopamine next thing you know you
never think an impact again that's what
Twitter is exactly yeah right we've
already seen it I mean that's how we
have influencers if if that weren't
possible we wouldn't have influencers
already but we have them because people
have already gotten that every time they
get that like they get oh I can do this
again I'll do something different I'll
do something more extreme I'm just so
black pilled on people's ability to
resist that because it's if once you can
plug into someone's head and affect the
way their brain produces chemicals in
the way in a way to make it imitate
experience then people will always
decide to go into that because the way
you experience the world is with your
brain but you still have to make money
somehow how do you make money because
you have to pay for this experience
somebody who is building this to make
money they you will have to pay them to
make money or to be in control well hold
on take a look at somebody who worked at
BuzzFeed news getting paid eighty
thousand dollars a year and the guy who
worked as a an apprentice Tradesman or
Union Tradesman making 50 60 a year
somebody who did no work there were
people at BuzzFeed who did almost
nothing when I worked for vice and for
Fusion I can tell you they're people who
literally did nothing and we're getting
six figures
they made money so you will have the
Haves and the have-nots you will have
the lower class working these jobs
mining Cobalt in Africa or wherever else
mining sulfur to build the machines for
the ultra wealthy chosen class of people
who are in the pods being their own mini
gods in their virtual universes we're
already basically there people in
foreign countries do effective slave
labor for for pennies in the dollar if
that to mine the materials that we can
have our video games our movies and then
while they're doing all that work some
dude gets a job at BuzzFeed and writes
the top 10 reasons why SpongeBob is is
is a a true true true truly masculine or
some nonsense and then they'll be like
look how ripped SpongeBob is and they'll
show a picture of SpongeBob flexing that
person's getting 100K a year or some
other crazy amount even if it's 50 40K
it's like they're getting money for that
heading to death in a field to harvest
the the rare Earths so that somebody can
write about how SpongeBob is you know
masculine or something
we're already there
that's that's that's the sad reality but
why why isn't that the discussion either
when you have I mean you talk about
these These are kids that are mining
it's kids that are mining this is slave
labor it's slave child labor and that's
a discussion we don't have like why do
we think that all of this new energy is
so it's it's not
it's not in the literal sense slave
labor it's it's it's viewed by these
corporations like this
you've got an area of the world with a
hundred thousand people who live there
and they're starving we can give them
one quarter per hour which means they're
no longer starving all they got to do is
mine that Cobalt for us
are they better off Starving in fields
or doing this job and that's what ends
up happening these companies are like
look we're giving jobs to these people
they're better off now than they were 10
years ago
and it's technically true and then we
sit in our VR pods and write for
BuzzFeed for a living now granted there
are a lot of Americans who do a lot of
really great hard work but I gotta tell
you man I I said if the working class of
this country saw how much the New York
media class got paid in the work they
did there would be a revolution
overnight they'd just be like these are
the woke people who are writing these
articles oh boy you got no idea lazy
entitled I think that's why you had this
surge of Donald Trump in 2016 because
suddenly people had this window into a
very rich man who was saying it's a
working class that we need to love these
are the people that make the world go
around and they went yeah I mean yeah
that's what we do and and that changed I
think that flipped the dynamic and that
was not something liberals were
expecting they could not foresee that
and so they spent four years saying okay
how do we how do we make sure that we
get in people's heads and we run
elections in a way that they vote for
the people we want them to vote for and
we get their ballots we do whatever it
takes and and we didn't do that because
we thought this anomaly could go on
forever that we could just love on the
working person and they would vote for
us the the big mistake Republicans have
made up until recent only they started
been correcting for it is no ground game
none the the the Democrats if the one
thing they're good at It's the weird
social
you know it's communism right they're
connected and they March in lockstep
with each other so it's very easy for
them in big dense Urban centers to go
door to door to bout Harvest and ballot
Chase but they use AI to do to do that
they use AI to locate that person they
can they can go okay I've got Tim Poole
what's it what is a message that is
important to him on our side you know he
he may lean conservative but we can get
him and they dig in and they go through
your brain essentially which is your
phone and they figure out exactly what
message you want and they hit you with
it and they hit what you with it so hard
but we're not doing that think about AI
commercials this this presidential cycle
is going to be nuts you're going to be
on Twitter and you're going to be
scrolling and then you're going to come
across a video where it's Donald Trump
going Phil Labonte you're the greatest
singer of all time listen vote for me
and we're gonna play All That Remains
everywhere trust me and it's going to be
a personalized AI ad where he's talking
directly to you now I don't think it'll
be Trump it's going to be some democrat
being like stop scrolling Phil I'm Gavin
Newsom we gotta get in there and make
this country work for the working class
trust me I didn't kill all those people
in the nursing homes that was the other
guy he's not gonna say that but you get
my point personalized AI generated
already they're I mean they're almost
there they're already going through like
you can be sitting next to me on the
same website you'll get different ads
than I get because they know what you
want to see they'll say okay wait this
is a pro-life Democrat so let's go to
them with gun control because they're
going to really want gun control so
we're just hit them over and over again
and we'll never talk to them about life
they'll never hear that message from us
and and that's how they but we need to
do that we need to stop ignoring the
fact that Republicans need to do that or
we won't we'll never win another
election that's even 15 wins if there
was one thing that like one thing I wish
Ronald McDonald would understand it's
that that it is her fault that the
Republicans have done so poorly the past
two elections they need the GOP needs to
get a new chair when they need to get
someone okay so let me let me argue that
you think are you on her side no no but
let me argue that point because it's not
the DNC winning elections it's the
organizations around the Democrats that
are winning elections that you don't
know the name of they don't have a
famous person they're not having
conventions and asking people to come to
them they have a ground game that is
outside of the DNC we've never created
these organizations we don't have these
we have organizations where we lift a
person up instead of lifting the people
up those are activists those activist
organizations are also why the left has
such
far left values now because the
activists that are out there on the
ground that are doing the work they're
motivated and they're ideological take a
look at this act blue on Wikipedia you
guys don't act blue is it's the digital
system by which Democrats fundraise
founded in 2004. the Republicans don't
worry they're on it they launched their
competitor win red in 2019.
15 years later the Republicans like hey
wait a minute the Democrats are raising
a lot of money somehow the Republicans
deserve to lose still what they still
deserve it what's even scarier is you've
got millions of new voters each election
cycle and they're all on Tick Tock and
you know who's not on tick tock
moderates and conservatives we're banned
it's bad guys that does matter
absolutely God and so they control the
most popular social media app right now
as Democrats do and they can push
whatever narrative they want
unchallenged look at Michigan they ban
everyone all all state officials are
banned except for Gretchen Whitmer I
mean think about that yes wow so think
about that there's only one person that
can reach the kids in the entire State
and she's willing to come out and say
well that's how I reach young people and
we're saying we're not going to be there
we have no one there I mean we don't
have we have no groups we are not doing
this the right way so we can sit here
and every time we have an election we
can say we're going to take this to
court and we're going to try to
overthrow it and we can spend two years
looking at that and then not be ready
for the next election or we can actually
get these organizations build a ground
team and stop making individuals famous
do the business of making people vote
that's crazy about tick tock I think
that I should be banned
I think that uh as far as a national
security threat I kind of agree I'm not
into Banning stuff generally like I'm
it's different when you have your enemy
brainwashing your your citizens I mean
that's a different situation I agree
with you I'm not into Banning I I think
that we people jump to Banning way too
quickly there's a difference when it is
you know you're you're Banning someone
in your own country from doing something
are you stopping a company from doing
something if it is an adversary who
wants a world domination that's when you
have to say Okay this is different I
don't like it's not only an adversary
like they literally we just had a couple
uh
police stations that the CCP was running
we had well yeah the FBI arrested a
couple uh Chinese Nationals that had
basically are policing the Chinese in
America that I mean look that's
International or that's you know
National sovereignty violation I like I
I'm not a China Hawk really but I I do
think that you at least have to say look
you can't try to brainwatch our kids in
Michigan we have a company that we gave
715 million dollars taxpayer dollars and
it is a Chinese owned Corporation
um they created an American version of
this company on their American Site in
English they had in their bylaws they
have to have a CCP operation on site to
infiltrate the Grassroots of the company
like this did they didn't screw this up
they it translated it I mean it's on
their website you know we're giving
Michigan dollars let me tell you what
the most valuable resource in the world
is it is water quite a bit of it is in
the state of Michigan because we have
the Great Lakes there is an absolute
loot strong reason they would want to be
in that location in the state of
Michigan to have control over the water
there either to harm the water or take
the water for themselves we do not want
to take a risk with our greatest natural
resource in the Chinese Communist party
and yet people are like we just had a
vote what like three days ago and the
Democrats said we're not going to say
that we don't want to associate with
businesses that say that they are
connected to it or trying to bring in a
Chinese Communist organization into
Michigan why would you vote again that
like this is insane but they are so
brainwashed and you're right they're in
lockstep that side is in lockstep
what do we do
and they're getting kids before they
even understand yep well youngkin came
out and he said I'm sorry he said to
Ford it Ford brought cattle to Michigan
but Junkin said to I'm sorry we will not
have a Chinese Communist company in our
state so you're not welcome here I mean
you have to we have to first of all we
have to win elections which like I said
it's a big job and we have to create
these organizations we have to say more
of us are going to get involved and
we're going to be the activist party
we're not going to make individuals
famous we're going to go to the people
we're not going to ask them to come to
us we're going to go to them and then we
have to say we're going to protect our
national security just just even our
national security is so valuable how
could we not be protecting that
yep
I don't know how confident I am to be
completely honest but I do think that
with Trump and many other Republicans
talking about exactly this ground game
organizing maybe and and I got to
actually combine these things with how
bad it's been under Joe Biden I feel
fairly optimistic I don't know how if I
if I if I feel like we've won like we're
gonna win we're gonna win a bunch of
Elections narrowly winning the midterms
is kind of scary it should have gone
historically Republican because the
swing with a midterm after abysmal
performance but because Republicans had
no ground game and were too busy
screeching about 2020 they really missed
a whole lot of what needed to get done
that may change from now to 2024. I'm
hoping
I hope so too I think you're I think
you're right I'm not I'm probably not as
as optimistic as you are
um I don't
trust that Donald Trump is going to move
Independence I think Independents that
don't like Donald Trump are probably not
going to be convinced to like Donald
Trump I would love to see them say I
don't care and I would love to be wrong
I would much prefer to see Donald Trump
uh win as opposed to you know Joe Biden
or anyone the Democrats are going to put
up but I still worry about whether or
not the independence can be persuaded I
wish I hope they can I want maybe
they'll be persuaded by how much they
hate Biden how much they like Trump well
there's not a lot of time for
Republicans to get on message to to
create that system that we're talking
about but this is important for
everybody honestly in the donor
Community to understand there's no
there's not a year off like Republicans
are like oh we're taking a year off now
no there's no years off Democrats don't
take a year off they do not even pause
they're like oh we need more money I
mean the minute they can seize on
something and they can start raising
monies like the the Nashville folks
every single Democrat raised money on
the Nashville guys getting kicked out of
uh the legislature whatever happened in
Nashville they re every our lieutenant
governor was like record-breaking money
raising off of this Nashville situation
like you have nothing to do with it you
know they're always raising money and
they have tons they've they have so much
more money than us are always motivated
because they are ideologues there are
the activists on the right are not
ideologues right they're not constantly
going they they want to be able to
separate their life from politics
activists on the left are the ones that
live the politics that they believe
because they're in a cult it's it's just
like any other kind of religion they are
ideological they believe that what
they're doing is right they want to
change the world and they are not tired
they have a whole system so they know
that they have to reach a voter at least
nine times I mean they have it down to a
science they start with Colorado there
they even have it written up this year
if you go through their data they have
Michigan is the next state where we're
taking the Colorado tactics to Michigan
they won Michigan they took the
legislature we had never we had 40 years
we had control of the legislature it
took the legislature Secretary of State
AG Governor everything and we had no
defense we were not on the ground at all
we were not in the mines or the heads of
young people or old people we are not in
the game we think that it's a concert oh
my gosh we got a thousand people to a
rally they didn't do that they're not
even campaigning people go why is Joe
Biden in the basement because he doesn't
have to be out there exactly they're
going to reach people anyway they're
going to go knock on your door and be
like hey how's it going see that piece
of paper can you sign that real quick
and hand it to me well because of
exactly what you said earlier about it
everything happens between here it
doesn't happen at a rally it can happen
in your head they can reach you they can
get here if you're at a rally you're
already on that side exactly like
they're not getting new people at a
rally no and the advantage they have in
big cities is two two Grassroots
activists can knock on a thousand doors
in a day you go to a suburb or a
conservative area 200 Doors in a day if
that because you got to drive
door-to-door so Democrats already have
the ground game Advantage then they've
been they got a 15-year head start on
online fundraising man Donald Trump one
of the things that got him to victory in
2016 was his meme army people posting
memes online that really worked and then
what did they do they got together cried
literally there's a Google leaked video
where they're crying about Trump winning
and then said we cannot let this happen
again that's why that's why people were
so upset just the other night when
Donald Trump was making the crowd laugh
he was clowning CNN if Donald Trump is
gonna win it's not going to be
complaining about uh 2020 it's not going
to be talking about how the Democrats
are all mean and blah blah and
complaining it's going to be making
people laugh and making people think
that he is the guy for them and making
people think that he can go and fix the
problem so clowning on CNN was literally
the best thing that he could have done
and that's why it's so important that
like Twitter stay a free a mostly Free
Speech platform because things like
memes and jokes they will be able to
affect the outcome now I'm not saying
that the memes are gonna win but you I
mean Donald Trump definitely got memed
into the White House to be fair Biden
makes people laugh too but they're
laughing at him
they're wrong
but does it really matter
no they they'll just they're voting for
The D that's exactly right yeah it
doesn't matter because they are able to
get to you no matter what you most
people because the average person does
not watch politics every day and you
know we're involved in it we see it we
so we are like oh how could anybody vote
for this but the average person is not
listening to the press conferences
they're not watching the news all the
time they're just not tuning in I mean
if you think about the biggest show
getting three million viewers of 330
million you know there most people are
not tuned into this I think they vote
rrd a lot of people are tuned out so
much they think politics just don't
affect their life at all and that's why
it's great that they can reach you with
text messages or on your websites with
an ad that's personalized to you because
you are not involved so the only message
you are hearing is the one that you want
to hear the average American is not
listening to everything they see they
they're being force-fed what they want
to hear and then they go I should go
vote it's going to be crazy when you
have an AI ad I mean when I was talking
about an AI ad that was saying like hey
Phil this is the president it's actually
going to be a bit creepier than that
where they're gonna they're gonna claim
it's a coincidence so we've already
we've already seen ads where and
everybody's experienced this I'll tell
you a story I went to Walmart
we were walking down where the aisles
and in the middle of the aisle was a big
stack of TVs on sale and we were like oh
look this is a 50-inch TVs they don't
sell for a couple hundred bucks we
walked past it I go home I go on the
computer on Facebook was an ad that
showed an image identical to what we
walked past and I'm like how the did
they know probably what happens is
they're they're tracking our location
data so they know we're at a Walmart and
they're trying to sell us this sale item
so Walmart does a campaign where they
sell these TVs they have all the
Walmarts do a similar stand and then
they advertise it we go to Walmart we
saw it but a lot of people have these
experiences where it feels like you're
being spied on have you ever thought
about something and then got an ad for
it yeah that creeps well but that could
be like you know if you if you're if
it's on mine you're you're gonna you're
gonna notice it whereas you probably
don't notice at other ads but what's
going to happen is you're getting an ad
where it's going to be it'll be a
politician saying
if if I'm gonna bet anything it's that
you're just like me hi I'm so and so
politician you know this morning I went
out for my cup of coffee over at
Starbucks and I grabbed a large cold
brew went down to the shop to check on
my car to see if it was fixed yet and
you're gonna be like that's literally
what I did
and you're gonna be like wow that's so
amazing he's just like me and it's going
to be an AI person tracking data from
you just saying what you did back to you
this is like this is totally a lot a
little bit off topic but that's why I
really think that I would love to see
some way to make your data protected by
property right laws so that way they
can't just use your data and make profit
off of you and make money because you
operate I don't know how it works I
don't have that kind of nonsense because
they've tried to do this with um the the
Chromebooks and stuff that they give to
kids because they give kids these
devices definitely you should definitely
not let your kids be dumping information
into Google because they're trying to
profile your kids they're going to do
psychological profiles on your kids
that's why people freak out about them
going to schools take a look at uh
Brittany Kaiser and she's working on
something called own your data she's the
she's the person who was in that
Cambridge analytica documentary where
she came out she was a whistleblower or
something but uh she's been working for
the past several years I know her
personally on
lobbying so that you own the data
meaning these companies can't just
collect it from you and then use it
however they want because it's yours I
don't know how that manifests right do
you get paid for it do you have to sign
a contract saying my data because
they're making money off of your labor
so there's got to be there's got to be
something there I think that's why I
think that that there is an argument for
it but even if it was just like you
can't use it right like it's you can't
just take people's data and then decide
how you're going to advertise to them
because it's their property even if
there isn't enough value there that you
could monetize it because maybe you
can't your individual you know personal
data alone isn't worth anything
fragments of a penny yeah you know but
it might be something where you could
say look this as a you know as a
collective thing that companies are
doing it's violating people's rights
it's tracking their their you know blah
blah blah and I think that that's at
least something worth considering you
know let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends if you really do like it because
that's the most powerful way to help and
uh let's let's read what you all have to
say
ready to rumble says Elon Musk voted for
Joe Biden never forget that
yeah but you know look people change
they learn I didn't vote for Trump in
2016. I voted for him in 2020. I'll vote
for him again so there were a lot of
Democrats who voted for Obama then voted
for Trump we're trying to convince
people you know if Elon Musk is now on
the side of free speech we've got to
keep the pressure up and tell him like
hey man we're keeping an eye on this
this world economic forum lady you know
I don't want to see any any funny
business all right
we got to be open to people changing
their mind too right
flooded timber Farm says Jeremy's
chocolate now has micro aggression sized
chocolate bars for pre-order I think I'm
gonna I think I'm gonna order a whole
bunch of them Mike they're little tiny
little little tiny ones and there's like
they come in bags and like that that's
probably better than the full-size bars
because not everybody wants to crack
open a full-size candy bar they need to
make a dairy-free dark chocolate I will
buy a whole bunch that's true you can
get the microaggression ones for
Halloween yeah yeah no to your
neighborhood absolutely yeah
you get put on a blacklist in your
neighborhood I I will say to to Jeremy
you need a dark chocolate you know
because uh some people don't have uh
Dairy some people are lactose intolerant
stomach Jeremy that's right but I am I'm
surprised I didn't do a dark chocolate
one
because I I like dark chocolate more
than milk chocolate but I gotta be
honest they're really good I don't
understand people that like dark dark
chocolate more than milk chocolate dark
chocolate's like
less of a candy to me I know I think
it's like it's like a grown-up candy
it's more like it's sophisticated
to me dark chocolate's like coffee you
know it's got less sugar it's got
antioxidants it's it's relatively good
for you it's got fat in it
all right let's let's see where we're at
lizziak says Tim did you know that Joe
Biden was born closer to Abraham
Lincoln's presidency than his own now
you do
yikes wow I heard that before
when was he born
uh I'm not sure how old is he now I
don't know is that is that true that
doesn't sound true I know that can't be
true but it might be she was born yeah
closer to Lincoln's inauguration I think
is what it was then to his own
inauguration so that sounds like it
might be true because he was what 78 or
something or yeah
yeah
yeah someone looking it up
you want to look up his birthday
doing it now all right while Phil does
that
free men Die free says I have always
suspected that Elon can't be trusted his
father was a technocrat elon's goals
require extremely high trust his angle
is to build trust people won't take
their implant without trust November
20th 1942
so and and Lincoln Lincoln's
inauguration was what uh
61. yeah I'm not sure it was like I
think the war ended in 64.
I'll Google that as well
so that's
I don't know is that right
how old was he when he was inaugurated
everybody's already giving us the answer
anyway in the chat what are they saying
he was inaugurated uh March 4th 1861.
it's just a mix of arguing about
chocolate and dates I'm trying to keep
up
all the dark chocolate lovers out there
I just feel like that's you're trying to
be healthy and I just want to be
unhealthy if I'm grabbing chocolate have
you tried Jeremy's chocolate yet I've
not so I'm very excited it's pretty good
I I have I haven't uh I do prefer the
she her I'm so this is unfortunate
because I do like almonds but I have a
light almond allergy oh so it's like I
can't really die I won't die but I gotta
go see her and and they're really good
anyway you know they're it's all
delicious but I've noticed so we ordered
a couple thousand bars the she her ones
are going way quicker it may have
something to do with people not wanting
to put hymns nuts in their mouths
I think it is because
I don't know I think people want to
enjoy their candy and if you have a nut
then it just becomes healthy too exactly
it's it's like the pure chocolate is
sweet and delicious and the nuts make it
a little bit healthy it's like
I mean if I'm in a full-size chocolate
bar it's because I'm doing something bad
I just want to indulge Roscoe says my
cat's breath smells like cat food
uh well okay
thanks for thanks thanks Ralph sick
Ralph Wickham
Brad ain't dead says Tim Elon and Tesla
are beholden to China remember that
world economic forum is a red flag for
sure can in truth only wait and see
don't cancel just yet wait you know uh
the majority of people wanted us to
cancel
but Anne it's tough because I want to
have that pressure
I want to be able to be like dude we're
paying a lot of money you better not
screw this up
so maybe it's more impactful to be like
I am I've got my finger on the switch
ready to say no as soon as she makes the
wrong move and starts you know doing
this weird woke stuff we're out but if
we leave now then there's no incentive
at all and it can be like I already lost
you have go nuts lady you know what I
mean right we can't be finicky about
things we have to know for sure
something's going to be bad it's tough
man man I don't know
Ito says for the love of God update your
Brave browser I'll consider it it was
funny Hassan did a video too where he
like zoomed in and he's like update your
browser and then I updated and I was
like there you go Hassan I updated the
browser just for you so you can comment
you know I love landlords
mind Fury says I voted for you last year
Tudor and was majorly disappointed that
you lost I hope you consider running
again someday well now that we've had
these horrible conversations tonight I
feel like I have to yeah I hope you run
again thank you if I inspired you with
my black pill garbage tonight to run
again and you win I don't feel like I
have done a positive for uh then we're
both doing something for Michigan there
you go tutor's gonna be like sitting at
home with like a bottle of Jack being
like what was Phil saying
oops
first time yeah just eating chocolate
bars being like
or we can make it more inspirational
than that and you get back and then you
you put on your suit jacket and you're
like I must run again that so like more
super hairy I like that better people
need me I can't let them knowing
happening drunk I'm actually like
motivated yeah
vanity says got my video on the on the
town hall election taken down for
election misinformation how can't we get
a bill started for the First Amendment
to be applied online
I mean I think that's that's BS they
took your video down Caitlin Collins was
telling Trump he was wrong you had the
debate right there in the town hall but
YouTube is uh I don't know run by bad
people for bad reasons you know it is
what Rumble exists we put all of our
Clips up on Rumble all of our videos are
on Rumble minds and uh and YouTube
that's it's unfortunate
um maybe if you know we really want to
put up our video put our videos up on
Twitter as well but now I'm kind of
worried you know with what with this
well economic foreign person but do you
so do you think that Elon decided to
hire this person and focus on the
technology side because I mean you said
does you just want to grow shows like
this do you think that he wants to be
the place that shows go
yes
but it was only really feasible with him
in charge it doesn't it doesn't even
matter who he gave the CEO to
yeah I mean if he gave the CEO position
to like Alex Jones I'm sure you get a
lot of people are gonna be laughing and
being like sign me up you know but
people would flee every time they get
angry so the fact that he stepped down
at all I think says to a lot of people
in the free speech space that it's not a
safe place to to run your business did
he just
ran a Twitter poll
I think he I think it's it's too much
work I mean dudes running SpaceX I think
SpaceX is the most important thing
humans are doing right personally it's
it's it's like going to Mars and going
other planets it's it's it's it's
inspirational it can bring us together I
really do believe in the space program
and he's the one leading it so I'm very
I hope he wins in that regard
but if he's not the CEO of Twitter am I
going to trust this lady I don't know I
I do not want to invest in another I
tell people if you're starting a new
show right now just go on Rumble like
just just start on Rumble because you've
got a lot less to worry about they're
not going to ban you I can tell you
don't know though you're like I don't
know what to think about this new woman
I think we all feel it all right and But
but so it it's simple the uncertainty
means to me do not invest money in it
unless I know it's going to be a good
invest I'm not putting money on it right
well it's only day one
it's not day one she doesn't start for
like three weeks right is it not day one
they just announce who it is
I wonder if like Tucker Carlson will be
like the canary in the coal mine because
if there's someone that's likely to
get the left worked up with something
that is actually fairly Anodyne but yet
they're gonna act like it's the end of
the world it's Tucker Carlson so if
Tucker you know is on Twitter and he's
putting up the content that we are used
to seeing the type of content that we're
used to seeing out of Tucker Carlson and
he's not getting Smackdown and he's not
getting treated poorly uh I think that
it might be a good indication and again
this is this is all just like you're
we're all kind of guessing anyways you
know she was I didn't know that she was
a trump fan or that she'd worked for
Trump before yeah I came here today so I
I'm still I don't know what to think I'm
also hired Bolton yes 100 I know and and
you know like we've all said musk has
also got certain things that don't seem
all that great so I mean as far as I'm
concerned I'm still kind of like well
I'm hoping for the best but what are you
gonna do Nick Ash says Tim please use
your platform to get Yingling to expand
their Market into the western part of
the country I'm in Western Illinois and
the closest place I can buy it is in
Indiana much thanks to all the
dissociated Midwest drinkers Ying
Yingling's the best that's pretty good
yeah they they need to be all over the
world what are they doing why why aren't
they expanding limit like what's the
limitation I didn't realize it was so
like
I grew up out here so it's a staple in
every bar every restaurant is it is it
does Michigan have Yingling I've never
heard of it what is it no that's what
she's me earlier I'm like I don't know
what that is oldest brewery in the
country
it's a it's a lager it's really good and
when the Bud Light thing happened they
posted a picture of someone holding up a
Yingling with the American flag behind
them
so it's like all right we like England
what do we have we got Bells yeah
overruns Michigan
all right how are they are they good
um I've I've had a couple Bells beers I
don't drink a lot I I personally um I
like to be it's an Israeli drink and I
based on my no it's like a it's like a
kind of citrusy liquor but Israeli beers
aren't bad like I'll drink a gold star
every once in a while but you can't
really get them here but I think they're
Heineken
like same company I might be mistaken
gold star oh really yeah oh interesting
I like Heineken too I don't drink a lot
though so I'm not a drinker so I'm like
the worst person I mean I don't really
drink either but you know if I'm gonna
have a beer right I rarely drink maybe
like two or three times a year I'll have
a drink I'm one of those people that has
the the alcohol allergies so I get
really red face it's just like that's
not worth it yeah save it for like
special occasions I like a sour beer
occasionally though I break out they
don't have a lot of alcohol
that's a good one all right let's uh
Chase says thanks to the crew I still
think it's funny the writers strike has
people out of work but my news hasn't
changed because it's not written LOL
yep I mean you'd think a lot of the a
lot of the corporate press would shut
down most so a lot of people get their
news from Jimmy Kimmel and Colbert and
they did shut down because it is written
but think about that there are large
swaths of this country think they're
informed because they listen to Stephen
Colbert Jimmy Kimmel the the one of the
most damaging things that has happened
to America in the past 20 years is The
Daily Show with Jon Stewart he's
literally made the idea of listening to
any conservative or Republicans as toxic
so people are afraid to say oh this
conservative has a good idea they won't
even say that a conservative has a good
their it is verboten you cannot say that
they had a good idea and that has done
terrible damage to America you're not
all that great Jon Stewart have you
watched this new show it's awful yes
he's like a huge jerk to people who come
on and in good faith to have a
conversation it's all clowning it's all
it's all bad editing it's it's it the
editing is as bad as that Jim Jefferies
editing the show on that Jim Jeffrey
show was when they were trying to you
know basically just Lampoon people it's
it's a really really horrible thing to
have made good ideas toxic because of
where they come from I don't understand
why people want to listen to someone
yell at someone else anyway why I don't
like that feeling of Jon Stewart danelli
made fun of everybody Jon Stewart's
whole stick was said something and then
said
look he did the Stewie head tilt you
know yeah okay all right John McGee says
saw a guy at the liquor store today
buying two cases of Busch Light he had a
man bun that's the story I'm not
surprised
you know but but hey I hope he's happy
with his Bush light some people are
saying Heineken is Anheuser-Busch I
don't know no I don't think so I don't
think that's true I don't drink that
much in the first place someone want to
fact check that real quick anybody's mad
they own so much it's hard to know for
sure it might be inbev
because inbev is the bird is the
European company is the Dutch or
something I'm just only gonna drink to
be now I know they're cool
Zima all right Tim Jake says if neural
link can read thoughts what happens to
the Fifth Amendment concerning
self-incrimination how do people with
security clearances protect classified
info it doesn't matter because the Fifth
Amendment doesn't exist because when you
fill out your taxes you're incriminating
yourself anyway right so I think it was
Dave Smith who said that like what about
the Fifth Amendment you're incriminating
yourself oh yeah interesting point
how does that make sense you just felt
your tax form and then you write like I
plead the fifth on like how much money
you brought in or why
like ah you don't know now what are you
gonna do like zero I plead the fifth
all right Heineken owns Heineken
apparently
Amsterdam the headquarters are in uh in
Amsterdam that founder was Gerard
Heineken and it doesn't look like they
have any parent company yeah I'm not
even sure if they really are the same as
gold star let's see Heineken gold star
so I might just be making things up yeah
I might be missing information here but
from what I found in a quick Google
search they're uh owned by Heineken
Jackie Oz says encourage all to
unsubscribe because it will get his
attention to make him notice how we feel
if she proves herself then we will
subscribe that's tough yeah I mean a lot
of people are already saying they're
canceling Twitter blue because of it I
did yeah well not just because of it but
partially because of partially I'm still
I'm still waiting for them to get back
to me about subscribing I'd like having
the subscription thing
um I sent in an email like two months
ago or whatever and can't even answer
but I canceled it so it's gonna be in it
runs until like next month is when
they're gonna charge me or when they
would charge me again so I've still got
the blue check to the end of the month I
feel like
the threat of shutting down will keep
them on their toes but if you but if
everyone unsubscribes then their
attitude is going to be like well if we
already lost them then what then we have
nothing to lose we want to make sure
they have something to lose we want to
give them something that they're scared
to lose if if you have someone who was
the highest rated show every week night
who gets canceled from Fox and goes to
Twitter and says I'm gonna take my
platform Twitter and they welcome him if
he stays I think you're right I think
that is like the measuring post if he
stays on there and can say whatever he
wants
at least I'll give you an indication but
you know at least the point you know
shows you which direction they're
pointed in so I mean initially like
remember just last week everybody last
week of the week before everybody was
like partying that Tucker's coming to
Twitter and it's the big deal and blah
blah blah you know
um so you know the audience is
definitely fickle but who knows what's
actually going to happen but you can I
mean there will be indications about
which direction it's going to go in and
well I also think that right now as long
as it is a beacon for free speech and
we're able to speak we have to stay
there because if you walk away based on
what you think might happen then you
have we're not going to have spaces you
know so we need those Open Spaces to
talk and if Tucker is there and we know
how demonized he's been then there's a
chance that that's going to keep us all
able to speak there's another thing that
I kind of want to point out I have
noticed and there's going to be people
that are going to give me hate for
saying this but I have noticed that
Brian krasenstein has been better on on
Twitter he has not been like I've seen
some things and I'm like he's actually
posting something good that's yeah
maybe the I don't know for sure because
I think one of the big divides between
the left and the right is the left
believes fake news and the right tends
to look for like tends to fact check or
and so this is why leftist personalities
don't go on other shows because they get
obliterated with fact checking the
krasensteins got suspended they lied
about what they did they were falsely
accused of I think doing some weird
stuff on Twitter and they maintained
that they had never done but they got
removed I think because they were
generating too much influence outside of
the dnc's control or the Democratic
party's control or the establishment so
they get banned they get falsely accused
and then their their attitude is like
were the conservatives right about why
people are getting banned did some
research talked to more people came back
said this is wrong people should be
banned for this started going on to
their shows and now they're probably
realizing like oh that one thing wasn't
true oh that one thing wasn't true
either this is what happens to a lot of
people you can still be liberal and have
liberal opinions I don't I don't mind
that I have liberal opinions but if we
agree on what's true because we fact
checked it yes there was there was
something that happened recently I can't
remember what it was in the Crescent
scene said guys don't jump to
conclusions or it was the it was the
profile like I released from the from
the Allen Texas shooter yeah and uh
Brian said something like just because
the profile was found doesn't mean it
actually has his profile we need to wait
for real confirmation on this like just
because it looks like it's I mean it's
true and I'm like that's actually a
really good really really good point
like he's right you know do you think
the Surfs guy is learning no he's been
on he's not capable he's not capable of
learning
impossible well so he is a really good
example is when
the guy from the serfs tweeted the right
finally admits that their concern about
grooming is indoctrinating kids into
queer Lifestyles which they view as
sexual
and it was funny that he referred to me
as the right finally admitting because
it's like bro dude my opinion is not
conservative like it is it is middle of
the road so it overlaps with some
conservatives and uh there were actually
several times where he called me woke on
the show and I'm like don't you get what
Centrist means but anyway uh he post he
posted that it means he is learning but
my response was that's finally admitting
it's literally been our whole argument
the entire time that you are
indoctrinating kids into a political
cultural lifestyle that does have overt
sexual connotations in it he didn't know
that listen he did not he did not know
that he wasn't a good guy Tim over here
you gotta get rid of the Beanie and get
the old good guy hat I like that the the
meth conversation was an aha I'm not
getting the benefit that I'm saying the
dude's completely ignorant oh then that
thing right yeah I see what you did
there well I didn't I didn't I didn't
say anything okay oh wait yes I did see
this yeah with the the baby right
because he was like a woman get an
abortion whenever she wants it's her
body it's her choice Sheamus asks so if
as long as the baby's in her body she
can do whatever she wants to and he's
like well it's her body it's her choice
and I go what about meth and then he was
like no because that would be
intentionally killing the baby and I I
didn't try I didn't try to win something
I genuinely went wait a minute because
like how can you say you can kill the
baby whenever you want but you can't do
math because it kills the baby whenever
you want I did not think he was going to
say that but he did and I'm like well
okay and then my response was I don't
understand what you're trying to say
because it makes no sense
and people called him out like you have
no formulated opinion on this you're
just regurgitating talking points we
talked to someone the other day that
said that this generation that's coming
out of high school now and for the last
five years they want to stand for a
cause and when asked what cause they say
we don't really care just stand for a
cause and so it's very easy to stand for
cause and not fully understand it
I think that's what we're seeing purpose
yeah I mean for a long time in this
country people had purpose in faith
family and community
that's mostly going away no family no
neighbors no faith so young people are
desperate for some reason to be alive
and they and they're not finding one but
now they're being given one social
justice if there's no God then you have
to create your own meaning right mankind
man has to find his own meaning if there
is no God and a lot of people that are
gen Z and Millennials are either
atheists or their agnostics and
without God or without a God to say this
is what is moral this is where you know
this is how you should live your life
man is really left with no actual
Foundation right so and it's hard for
people to make their own morality you
know because you have to you have to
have principle to have morality you have
to have things that you believe are
actually real and if you don't see any
reason for existing at all what does any
of it matter because you can stand for
regardless of your religion or lack
thereof and it's
save women's sports
anybody who can get on board with this
one it's a great cause to stand for all
right mm maisel says I'm the last
of the Boomers in my 50s we are not all
brain dead followed you from the
beginning and will until I quote age out
big fans stay real so age out is the
polite way I say of
passing on you know I don't say like you
know my fear is that when the Boomers
age out we're in deep trouble yeah you
know I like Gen X you know they did a
lot of really great work a lot of the
stuff I grew up watching uh Boomers made
Star Trek the Next Generation which is
the best show ever and uh so I'm deeply
appreciative of that but I think Boomers
did a lot of really good stuff and they
did a lot of bad stuff too but I think
you know all the good stuff that
influenced me I'm a big fan of and they
vote better they they vote better than
the younger Generations the younger
Generations are the fault of the old
generations of course but my fear is
that when the boomers are no longer
voting there's going to be a hard shift
boom towards communist weird Marxist
policy you don't think people vote
differently as they get older I'm that's
I'm sort of hopeful that that happens I
I do but it's mostly because they have
kids and now we just have everything
we're just gonna be watching our lives
no but based on what you're telling you
so my my one hope I suppose is we may
see a big shift leftward when uh the
Millennials may be a blip a leftward
spike in the voting patterns when the
boomers are no longer voting when they
pass on when they age out when they
retire to the point where they're no
longer involved
Millennials are going to do a big spike
leftward but I'm hoping that because
they abort all of their children that
there will be substantially less of
leftists in the future
and look
I say it all the time they never respond
because they can't respond
I told Lance the guy from the Surfs I
said y'all are sterilizing and aborting
your kids I don't care I'm not a
conservative I'm not one of these
pro-life conservatives begging you to
save your kids I'm sitting here being
like no go ahead get rid of them 50
Years it'll be a Conservative Christian
country what do I care and then their
response is just stone-faced I have no I
don't know what to say to that it's true
you don't have kids and like you point
out they say we're coming for your kids
and I'm like you're not going to win
that fight you're going to win some kids
from some parents but we're already
seeing the backlash with Loudoun County
we're already seeing parents say no to
the woke stuff in schools and it's
causing them to freak out it's causing
the FBI to call them terrorists because
they're losing so you give it 20 years
and there's going to be more
conservative voters you give it 40 years
exponentially more you combine the fact
that conservatives have more kids with
liberals abort their kids and it is just
mathematically impossible for the left
to win so I'm just like look guys we got
to be vigilant we got to stand up we got
to call it out to make sure they don't
indoctrinate this crazy stuff into the
kids other than that we just wait there
therefore abortions up to any point
it's politically correct for them to be
my response to them is thank you for
aborting your kids you're making the
future better they never respond
and I'm I'm waiting for them to they
just won't because they don't want to
bring up the political debate of we are
excising ourselves from from the country
so I'm like okay well you know you're
going to get conservatives who are
pro-life being like that's so horrible
no we can't let them do this to the
children and my attitude is like no
you're right you you are they shouldn't
do it but like politically it's out of
my hands so and and it I mean to your
point of how much can you control by
government is that is the question that
Republicans need to ask about the
pro-life message is
we this is a culture issue if you want
to impact culture you can celebrate the
wins in the Life movement but if you
think that you can change the minds of
liberals and this control they have over
this in an election that's not how
you're going to do it
yeah well I think uh I think we'll wrap
it up here so if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends become a member
at timcast.com it's an amazing Friday
night I hope you guys are having a good
weekend already chilling out relaxing
you can follow the show at Tim cast IRL
you can follow me personally at timcast
tutor do you want to shout anything up I
just check out the podcast tutor Dixon
podcast we would love to have you there
right on I am Phil Labonte lead singer
of All That Remains I am Phil that
remains on Twitter I am Phil that
remains official on Instagram and the
band is All That Remains you can check
us out on Spotify Apple music YouTube
all that stuff
and you can find me on Twitter at TM
Silverman or on Instagram at taylormay
Silverman shabbat shalom and happy
Mother's Day to all the moms happy
Mother's Day happy Mother's Day happy
early Mother's Day yes
uh you can follow me at Kellen PDL and
heineken's good uh 2B is good but buy
American Beer so go buy Yingling uh you
can probably order it online at this
point but yeah I only drink on vacation
fair enough
thanks for hanging out everybody we will
see you with Clips throughout the
weekend and then we're back on Monday